what's goody hopper at the verse welcome
back to hot breath the show where you
learn comedy from the pros i am your
host comedian joel byers and our mission
here is to cultivate the next generation
of great comics by interviewing today's
great comics and our guest today
after almost 30 years in this comedy
game he has been one of the most
respected on and off stage so far mainly
known for his work behind the scenes as
one of the most respected
writers and producers and show runners
but now he has released his second
netflix special produced by
a little guy named kevin hart and he is
finally getting the light he deserves so
please welcome to the hot breath of
verse the one and only
david arnold everyone welcome to the
show
oh
yeah
david a arnold because if you don't put
in the a you get the white guy that does
the soundtracks for james bond that's
not bad david a arnold my bad fam i'm
over here trying to gentrify your name
that's on me man
so when everybody looks me up and they
look up david arnold they're like this
don't look like the
great person
we've appropriated the name too
yes yeah but i i realized i had to do
that when i realized it was another
david arnold that was also successful
well i've got to ask i mean first off
congrats on the special it is lights out
funny which is no surprise here but
thank you as a comic as you being in
this game for almost 30 years
from cleveland you moved to la not
knowing anyone you're working as a nurse
grinding it out on stand-up you're in
and out of rehab three times and now
you arrive here at your second netflix
special
what as a comedian i've been in the game
12 years so i'm curious what does it
feel like right now what like what it
what is you've had this success behind
the scenes but now you're you're getting
your shine fam what does this feel like
right
it feels like it's about time
like
perfect timing because i'm ready for all
of it
it feels like uh
this is exactly where i should be i was
driving by
the down sunset and i saw a billboard uh
on the side of the laugh factory which
is the world famous lab factory in
hollywood and i saw you know they have a
big billboard that they put up there for
the netflix specials that come out and
mine is up there and
it oddly feels like that's exactly where
i belong
when i see it i they have a huge one up
in times square right now a huge digital
billboard of myself and my special in
times square and it oddly feels
right
and i think i can say that because i've
been doing i've been working so hard for
28 years
to
get to this place and when you've done
the work you're like
yeah like you know what i mean like it's
you know what it's like it's like if you
worked out eight right
you know consistently and then somebody
said wow you've lost 30 pounds you would
think of course
i've been doing the work like so that's
how it feels you know what i mean that's
exactly how it feels
i i'm curious how low did it get for you
because i know you had moments of like
even b-e-t like saying you're not black
enough to do a show with them and things
like that like how low did it get for
you to reach this high
i think that was probably one of the
moments i was in development for a tv
show that i had been developing for a
while with kevin and then a new
president took over the network he
started at hulu and went to another
place and settled at bet
and they
one of the you know the the the things
that i heard back was basically
you know you you're not black enough for
you you don't look like what a black man
looks like in all of this stuff
and that was one of the moments where it
hit me hard because it was the first
time that i was up for and i had been
developing my own tv show
and thought that it was going in the
right direction and then all of a sudden
because the show actually got order to
series
picked up for 10 episodes we were about
to start we were putting together our
team and writers and then the president
got fired and they brought a new
president in and she was like i was one
of the first things on the chopping
block she was like yeah this guy's not
marketable he doesn't look like what a
black man looks like we need somebody to
that our audience will respond to
and that [ __ ] just hurt me and that's
when i started posting videos with my
cell phone i started posting social
videos on social media with me
interacting with my wife and kids and
how you know it feels to be a parent all
these things i've been doing on stage
and then i also took some of the stand
up that i have been doing from 15 years
ago that nobody had ever seen
and i started posting it in rants i
would do these little rants about you
know taking out the trash and bad
drivers and
you know bad waitings like whatever my
rant was and i started putting it up on
instagram and social media one minute at
a time and they just
ate it up
and my my social media went from
1200 followers to well over a million on
all my platforms
and my facebook page i think has been
translated into like five different
languages in several different countries
around the world damn getting that
facebook money
i know so it's been a journey so it's
been a it's not been one thing it's been
a lot of little things that have gotten
me to this space
one one question i always ask on here
and we've interviewed over 400 comedians
at this point and yeah it's like your
worst bombing story or like getting
booed it's just one you will never
forget
of san diego a theater called fourth and
b
uh i was i went down there
place holds about 2 000 people
i went down there to up to watch a
friend perform who was on the week
before me they were doing a weekly show
so i go down there
to watch my boy and just get a sense of
what's happening in the
in the um you know in the room that
night
my boy is there performing the host says
hey you here headlining next week you
want to go out and do five seven minute
set just to fill the room out i'm like
sure i go out there i do start into the
set
start doing like going to church with my
grandmother something i can't remember
what it was but what i remember is they
started to get restless very quickly
and hopefully you know they started
going
making that noise like you know like
they bout to boo boo
and he was about to come up into a full
fledged boo
and i don't know if you've ever been
booed by 2 000 people at once
wind
from the boo
blows you off stage like it was like
it's nothing like 2 000 people
all at once agreeing you ain't [ __ ] like
that's exactly what it was and i just
walked off the stage and the host was
like what'd you do and i was like they
started blowing me i had to leave
and so i told my boy that i went to go
see performing tonight i said listen man
i'm not
i'm not coming back to that club i'm not
doing it next week cause like at that
night when you
left the show they would pass out flyers
for the next week's show
and
my picture is on the flyer so i'm sure
people were getting the picture in the
flyer going this is we just booed five
minutes ago i ain't coming back here
next week like you know that had to
happen
and i left the
theater that night walk into my car
um
flyers all over the ground footprints on
my face where people had stumped and i
stole my car for like two hours and i
was like i can't go back there next week
my friend told me i had to
he said you gotta overcome every fear in
comedy
and i rewrote my set i tweaked it
i went back the next week got a standing
ovation i killed
and an old lady up to me and it's like
baby
we was here last week i was she said i
was here last week when we boo joe
ass came back and redeemed yourself and
i'm thinking you're the one that started
the boo didn't you you were the one
that is that that boo story that bomb
story i will never forget it's one that
stays with me
yeah failure is the best teacher
especially in this comedy game
because you can't avoid it
you can't avoid failure i tell people
this all the time you know i teach one
of the largest stand-up comedy classes
in the country
and we have well over 300 plus people on
my waiting list and
i've told everybody this
you have to fail
because it's the failure in comedy that
will make you
figure out if you really want to be a
comedian you know what i mean because
it's like boxing if you're gonna box you
gotta know you're gonna get hit in the
face several times and it's going to
sell you gonna get your nose broke
possibly you gotta love boxing or think
it's for you that much to go in the ring
and keep getting your face popped and
that's what like doing stand-up is like
so
it ain't that's why the name of my
netflix special is it ain't for the week
that's one of the reasons why it is a
must-see it honestly like it gave me
chills like earthquake special when he
dropped his on netflix and it's just
like boom
boom
boom like as a comedian we just sit back
and watch like oh no that's where the
bar is it's like we have so much work to
do
quake has been doing that
for 30 years that's why his name is
earthquake because when he gets on stage
the room is like shake
i went up behind earthquake one time
in atlanta i've been doing comedy three
months he had been doing comedy for
years and when i tell you
they swallowed me whole
like it was like taking a minnow and
throwing him into the ocean is what it
was like like i never survived
like it was i wasn't on stage 30 seconds
before it was clear
that i did not belong in the same space
as this man and so to now have both of
our netflix specials out at the same
time and for him to hit me up and go
dude
wow yeah it makes me feel good you know
it's been a 28-year run so
and uh
yeah and as we'll uh we'll land the
plane here because uh david's actually
on set right now he actually took a
break
from from from his job to do this and we
appreciate but i think this is such a
relevant question for all young comics
that uh ryan skrilla asked how long did
it take you to find your style slash
voice and what are tips for someone who
is struggling to find that
it took me remember this answer is not
the same for everybody because somebody
could walk and step into their purpose
in two minutes
and somebody else like myself i gotta
honestly say it took me about 10 years
and
um
yeah 10 or 11 years i
i've always done
material about my life and my family
that's always been my thing right that's
always in my wheelhouse
but i would just talk about that
without my point of view about that
you know what i mean i could tell you a
funny story about how my dad
didn't only allowed us to have one glass
of juice a day
because we are kids and that was the
funny story he had drink tickets that he
passed out all of that stuff is funny
but when you start to add your
commentary about how you feel and think
about the things you go through that is
when your point of view starts to happen
my point of view came to me around 2007
and i've been doing stand-up since 97
i've known
six so this is 11 maybe 12 years
and i started doing rants on social
media
that 2008 is where it really started to
crystallize rants on social media and i
had this little toilet paper that i it
was a rants that i would do called life
with dave
and i would and if you go back on my
youtube channel you can see him way back
on there where i would do you know bad
tippers you know uh uh you know
telemarketers like i had all but i
started doing these rants
and
as i kept doing them i started to see
people's reaction to it and then i
started to realize oh this is my point
of view
and i kept going then i started to apply
it to my life oh my kids do this and
this is how i feel about it my wife does
this and this is how i feel about it
that is the point of view
that is what it takes comedians a minute
to get and you have to get through a
stage of
oh i wonder what people are going to
think
oh i wonder if my
my day job is going to see this and
think this this and this
you got to get through all that [ __ ]
because none of that
when my wife my boyfriend doesn't like
when i say none of that's going to work
not and be real and stand up to the
level in which you need to be real at in
order to
compete with the best
i've been lucky to not have that so it's
different for everybody but if you know
the goal to find your voices to every
single bit and every story that you tell
your goal has to be to ask yourself what
is how do i feel
about what i'm talking about
so yeah i do family material too and i
talk about like my wife loving the dog
more than me and it's like a lot of
silliness right now so it would be like
literally how do i feel about her loving
like i'm jealous or i'm envious i want
to kill the dog things like that i work
all day i come home to make sure that
you have and the dog's food the dog's
water is fresh
but i get leftover so and so
maybe i need to it's i me i i when you
start getting to that
and you're not narrating from the
outside giving people
about what's happening outside and you
get inside and you tell people
she's i come home i've been working all
day i'm looking for a meal she says it's
in the microwave i look down the dog's
bowl is fresh with
that's what i'm wondering what what what
about me when the dog was eating better
than the man who bought the food for the
dog we got a prop that's my point of
view point of view man
yeah erica just said she joined your
wait list yeah you just put on a quick
master class david
thank you so much for squeezing this in
your busy schedule man you i apologize
for all of the mishap i really do i love
you know being able to sit up and talk
comedy yes if you follow me on instagram
it's the david arnold my new netflix
special my second one it ain't for the
week my first one fat ballerina is now
trending on netflix as well because
people found that
and we're going to i'm going to announce
very soon
a weekend intensive of my stand-up class
in los angeles here because i'm on tour
i'm in the middle of a 40 city tour as i
prepare for my third netflix special and
so i'm i can't do a six-week class as i
was doing before so i'm gonna do
weekends i'm gonna do like six hours on
a saturday and six hours on a sunday and
do an intensive so that announcement is
coming very soon so we will keep an ear
out my friend thank you so much for
taking the time david i'll link
everything in the show notes and uh
thanks for the inspiration buddy
yeah man good luck to everybody y'all
stay doing it have a good day buddy
please
whoa
okay then
okay then
yo
what
that was just like a hurricane of comedy
information right there holy cow